welcome to this press conference by the
European Union represented here by the
European Commission President Yuka the
President of the European Council mr.
Donald Tusk
without further ado I give the floor to
president Juncker do is no better place
for this is cd20 summit
than here in osaka a vibrant merchant
city known as the nation's Hitchin as we
prepare to discuss the future of the
global economy over the next few days we
should inspire ourselves but the cities
which history and innovation and
openness we met we meet at the time when
the global economy continues to move
despite some clouds forming on the earth
amongst this uncertainty Europe's
economy continues its stable and
sustainable growth we are now in the
seventh consecutive year that we can
only growth on average 2% with every
member states contributing to that
progress investment is finally back to
the pre-crisis server unemployment is at
the record low since the turn of the
century and more people are in work than
ever before 240 million to be exact
thirteen point four million of those
jobs have been created since November
2014 a large part of the success is due
to the fact that Europe is open for fair
business European Union is number one
trading partner for 80 countries around
the world we have 73 trade agreements in
place and under the Mandate of this
commission alone we have opened up trade
relations with 15 countries from Canada
to Japan via Ukraine and aguado
and with more good news to come this
Sunday the Commission will sign the new
you Vietnam trade and investment
this spirit I will take our great
relation to the next level but it will
also help strengthen our respectful
human environmental and Turkish rights
this is what youth trade policy is about
we believe in trade because it works
fast and for others 36 million roughly
new European Union are supported by
exports and almost 700,000 to small
businesses benefit from international
trade but we are not naive with traders
in the last five years we have adopted
42 new and dumping and empty subsidy
measures and we have introduced
investment sweetening mechanism and I
hope that the Commission's proposal for
an investment of unit instrument will
also be adopted swiftly these shows that
will send up for ourselves if others do
not play by the rules but it also
reveals the loopholes in the global
trading system which have created
Detroit tensions we see across the world
we have to tackle this issue head-on in
this spirit I believe that the Global
Forum on steel excess capacity should
have its mandate extended so that it can
deliver on the existing commitments we
are also working closely we do not heed
States and Japan as well as China and
others on reforming the world trade
organization and creating a level
playing field we must tackle issues such
as unfair industrial subsidies and the
forced transfer of technology this can
only be done with the g20 as a core
group working this forward this is about
ensuring that the rules of the game fit
for the modern digital economy this is
why European Union free supports Prime
Minister arbitrator free-throw with
trust initiative to facilitate the
cross-border flow of data among
countries with high levels of privacy
protection
this cooperative approach also sums up
the hoops
attitude the g20 and the multilateral
based system as a whole and nowhere is
this more important and when it comes to
climate change Europe will continue to
lead the way as we did in Paris in 2015
we have ambitious 2030 goals for the new
bill and energy efficiency which we must
focus on implementing we will do this by
making sustainable financing the central
part of our financial system from the
capital markets Union and we will invest
25% of the next home term you appeal
budget in climate action but climate
change will not stop in 2030 and taste a
strong and significant majority of
member states of the Union to support
the Commission's climate neutral
strategy for 2050 I believe it is the
way forward it is good for the planet
and it is good for business on all these
issues
you will be swagat early in the term and
work with our g20 partners to offer
stability and confidence to earth needs
we share many of the same challenges and
we are undergoing many of the same
transitions whether it be climate
digital or technical change the issues
that we will discuss over the next few
days cut across boundaries societies and
economies they require the concerted and
comprehensive response between
multilateral rules based system our
message to the world is clear and simple
Europe is committed to upholding and to
be necessary updating the rules-based
global system and we are ready to work
with everyone to make that happen
thank you good morning let me just add
to what President Juncker has said first
of all I want to stress how much we
appreciate the tireless efforts of the
Japanese presidency
making sure that the summit will bring
the world's closer to solving key
challenges of our times the leadership
of Prime Minister his personal devotion
and diplomatic skills impressive and
really unique I know that with the host
like him we are in good hands
before coming to Osaka I visited
Hiroshima and Nagasaki where I met with
survivors of the nuclear bombings they
understand only too well the value of
international cooperation because they
know what the global conflict may lead
to I promise them to bring words of
warning to the g20 participants a global
stage cannot become an arena where the
stronger will dictate the conditions to
the weaker where egoism will dominate
over solidarity and where nationalistic
emotions will dominate over common sense
we should understand that we have a
responsibility not only for our own
interest but above all for peace and the
safe world order finally let me share
one reflection
thanks to my jetlag I was able to read
the whole interview with President Putin
in the Financial Times I have to say
that I strongly disagree with the main
argument that liberalism is obsolete we
are here at Europeans also to family and
univocal I defend and promote liberal
democracy whoever claims that liberal
democracy is obsolete also claims that
freedoms are obsolete that the rule of
law is obsolete
and that human rights are obsolete for
us in Europe these are and will remain
essential and vibrant values what I find
really obsolete authoritarianism
personality cult the rule of oligarchs
even if sometimes they may seem
effective thank you okay we have time
for some questions let's start with
Valentina yeah hi with The Wall Street
Journal I have a question for mr.
Juncker on trade and one for mr. tusk on
Iran and mr. Juncker what is the EU
strategy also with your partners here to
address the us-china trade conflict and
to mr. tusk you you were mentioning this
very start emotions and and observations
from your visit at Hiroshima
given that Iran is now threatening to
pull out of the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty what is the
message here from the European Union on
well the nuclear deal with Iran thank
you I have a jet lag but this was not a
sufficient with reason to reach the
interview president arms four months I
was using this chat like 2v2 communique
which normally I'm not doing and I'm not
the only one who is not with the company
case nobody in fact is within the
communities but we are spending hours
days at nights on this communique and
this work is still under way the trade
relations between China and the less
difficult they are contributing to the
slowdown of the global economy and in
our talks both with us and with
the Chinese authorities president Prime
Minister I was drawing attention to the
harmful impact this controversial matter
is creating and I would be glad if I
would have a meeting only questions on
the Chinese the US great relations
you never mentioned in that context but
we made it very clear to our respective
doctors that Peter want to be treated
with benign neglect when it comes to
maybe agreements between China and the
US you may know the U has come an
official position here and let me just
repeat our our statement tensions in the
Gulf are serious concern we follow the
developments closely and are passing the
message to all on the need for maximum
restraint and the escalation and to
avoid miscalculation we need to keep
channels of communication open we
strongly urge Iran to continue the for
implementation of all its commitments
under the nuclear deal and we take very
seriously the possibility of any breach
of its commitments maintaining the
nuclear deal is in the regional and
international security interest the EU
is committed to the deal as long as Iran
continues to uphold it we will continue
to monitor Iran's compliance to death
good morning a question to president
yoga in Germany if I may hey yo cuz I am
shall i negates one skip will ellipse
the zephyr Comte is a club so I'm
spectacle is enough Trump's loud mister
don't in bunch nourished after after
lots of thing and the question to
president tusk
how are the consultations on the EU top
jobs going and how high is pressure and
how close are you to a solution sorry
I'm we don't have to mind repeat your
question I have to give an answer in
German because it's for the German TV
just the title okay so I'll repeat it in
English the question was how you have
seen quite a lot of g20 summits how is
how is in your observation the the
situation deteriorating in this club
where everybody is just watching the the
tempo of the American president and his
wish to to impose no tariffs on somebody
else the gates once you give the
organization in sight had competent F
understand phenomena in acid ominous
others fear the state function alone and
as I'm a current president now schizos
feather Andrei Ivanov Timothy candies
you for bringing us a rock tune it's not
necessary these guitars gibson Knutson
canon comes in
so did a little bit us of Tama Huata
that was clear for everyone
okay so here I'm in the permanent
contact with all the leaders also here
in Osaka only yesterday I had 12 or 13
phone calls and it means that I'm still
in the middle of the consultations I
will meet also today and tomorrow
my colleagues here in Osaka focus and I
will continue my talks on the process of
illuminations don't expect you know
white smoke here in Osaka and what I
feel that we are you're closer to the
solution that's still too far to to say
something more concrete today okay let's
have a question for the Japan based
good morning thank you very much
hey anything yeah hope it's a bush
mechanic I shouldn't issue this before
forgive citizen well that makes it nice
crater that was just a quick reading and
Luxembourgish a question have you gone
almost which will continue in English a
question for both presidents if I'm a
French president a man where Michael
said yesterday that he has a red line
when it comes to the communique of the
g20 he seemed to threaten that France
might not sign the final statement if
there isn't a strong review on climate
change a strong view on the fight
against climate change do you share that
red line and a second question are you
seeing the United States currently
standing in the way of a strong final
statement from the g20 on climate change
thank you I do think that we need this
one statement in climate change we
agreed on the couple of sentences
February when Osiris last year and I
couldn't accept a watering down of what
has been said in Versailles
it's our self obligation to help premise
the other with also with a final
statement from here from Osaka and if
you may know president Jung called
special coordinate coordinate Tory
meeting among the leaders French press
comprehension that if I mean wiser after
this meeting my lunch don't have colors
this concludes our press conference both
presidents have to join the EU leaders
for the coordination meeting thank you
all
I have a question for mr. younger on
video
I have been tweaked to be interviewed